ask the question I mean this to be sweet
and not anyway more but I think about
these things I think about mortality all
the time and I wonder if you ever think
about you know as we move along and get
on in years and make this journey
through life do you think about
mortality a lot do you think about death
you know and there's children and you
know all that you're telling me
absolutely and it's a fruitful [ __ ]
series for thoughts it's a it's a
fruitful thing to think about wise
people tell us yeah we could die at any
time so to make the most out of this
moment and life Skiz has to do with
maybe hasn't it has to do with your
awareness that it could end right as we
know it can and yes as you get you know
even not philosophically but making
potatoes wise we're both getting and I'm
getting more than you closer to the end
than the beginning and so it could more
likely happen at any time and yes nice
smiling as you say all this we head
towards the tomb well life is a
spectacular mystery you know yeah I'm
with you on this by the way I believe in
this oh I do too and kids cuz you know
better than I do now but I have a three
and a half year old and a one and a half
year old oh yeah
I'm thinking about all the time what my
you know what I will leave with them and
leave to them practically you know I
think of my clothes in fact when I buy
something and included in a permanent
collection I think G is this something
that I just got this watch is this
something that sometime I could hand on
they'll be wearing yeah and Charlie says
who's talking up a storm now goes
through my closet he likes clothes too
and he goes mm-hmm I go you want to wear
this yes yes I want to wear all your
clothes okay well good that's I mean I
think it's nice that but the idea of my
kids going through my clothes and going
we'll get this when you're dead
yeah nothing's gonna happen to you for a
long time I won't allow it
you're a precious gift the American
people I read that
[Applause]